c'est hier que la chaîne cryptée la plus
cultes de la télé fêter ses 35 ans plus
de trois décennies au cours desquelles
l'irrévérence la déconne l'innovation
ont changé le paysage télévisuel
révélant au passage quelques uns des
artistes les plus doués de leur
génération lancée en 1984 par pierre
lescure et andré rousselet la chaîne à
péage avait de quoi étonner payer pour
la télé un concept inédit en france mais
très vite grâce à une offre mêlant
cinéma sport et contenus pour adultes la
chaîne réussi à se faire une place
quatre ans seulement après sa création
les guignols de l'info sont inventés un
format innovant qui permet de traiter
l'actualité politique avec irrévérence
et provocations alors qu'est-ce qui lé
long dur et que les fans n'ont pas pour
cela michel est connu à ses services
militaires non c'est la [ __ ] habite ce
sont les nuls menée par alain chabat
chantal lauby dominique farrugia et
bruno carette qui feront rire toute une
génération
c'est le bouton chantal le mouton marron
juste juste avec le nom pas celui-là si
l'autre le boulon doute non c'est les
essuie-glaces suivront nulle part
ailleurs groland la grande famille et le
grand journal entre autre canal c'est
aussi des programmes courts culte qui
verront le jour sur cette antenne comme
le sav d'omar et fred simplement bonjour
ou encore la série bref des programmes
cultes qui ont lancé de nombreux
artistes parmi eux les nuls de koné
garcia omar et fred kihn khojandi et
beaucoup d'autres bref 35 ans après
avoir vu le jour canal+ est toujours là
et a marqué l'une des plus grandes pages
de la télévision même si en 1984
rares étaient ceux qui y croyaient
[Applaudissements]
35 ans alors vous avez choisi chacun
voilà un intrus culte de canal plus on
les a classés de la 10e à la première
position valérie benaïm vous êtes 10e
vous êtes arrivée dernière mais bon
voilà on fait partie du top 10 ça pas
mal vous avez choisi par les choisit la
grande famille à la paix entre 91 et 94
et l émission d'accueil à midi avec jean
luc delarue c'est là on a découvert
aussi jean pierre coffe c'était une
émission formidable moi je trouvais que
c'était voilà c'était de la révéler jean
luc delarue avait trépassé après sur
france 2 16 ans exactement
voilà et regarder la grande famille
c'était sa star y en 10e position
moi je crois que ce qui est grave c'est
ceci jean-luc regarder ça est ce que la
caméra peut nous prendre ça voyez ça
c'est la charcuterie que nous avons
acheté ce matin ça a été acheté chez un
charcutier c'est nulle part ailleurs
vous voyez la gueule que ça ce truc là
alors une seconde je me lève je passe
devant vous et je mets ça là simplement
pour que vous puissiez regarder la
différence voudrais pas qu'on s'imagine
une seconde que c'est monsieur qui a
fait ça vous voyez ça vous voyez ça donc
on va me dire oui au vous êtes vous êtes
un con vous allez jeter ça oui je le
jette pas ce que ça co2 c'est pas de la
charpie crise est la mer alors que ça
c'est bon voilà la différence
ça se voit à la couleur
alors c'est vrai que ça avait révélé
jean luc delarue c'est incroyable et
jean pierre coffe y avait également
yamaha ec centre de voir the sleeper
chroniqueur il avait florian gazan alors
c'est en 10e position en 9ème position
c'est vous kelly la bande à fifi exact
nanar ici sur ce plateau
c'est vrai la bande à fifi conquise
grave et c'est vrai qu'ils s'étaient
dans le grand journal
mais avant de faire des cartons au
cinéma on voyait qu'ils avaient un goût
prononcé pour le cinéma puisqu'on a mis
un extrait dans lequel il interprète
star wars mais à leur façon et c'est
vrai qu'on avait oublié que la bande à
fifi aussi été sur canal plus ce qu'ils
étaient sur m6 aussi je sais pas s'il
était avant sur m6 ou avant ou après non
après après sur une cinéma l'ennemi
carson sida et batna cartonne partout
partout si je suis là ce genre parce que
je suis allé voir votre film un ticket
dans l'espace c'est franchement j'ai
adoré et j'ai tellement adoré que moi
aussi ça m'a donné envie de voyager dans
l'espace
là où j'ai rencontré quelqu'un avec nous
mais flirter aussi paraît il s'agit de
l'extraterrestre dans la guerre des
étoiles qui est très poilu à couiza mais
je suis pas convaincu rien sauf que là
c'est chou bacchus et la femelle
oui j'ai vécu
[Applaudissements]
l'idée des poilus je suis pas que décidé
de chanter une petite chanson
d'accord c'était vrai chemin qu on va y
aller 3 4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
avant la fin
car avant la physique aux jeunes je les
aime trop yatera qui va couronner son
film va bientôt ouais je vous le dis
donc on va on va les soutenir à fond
quand vous qui vous qui fait revoir ces
images aux 35 34 et plus raymond vous
êtes numéro 8 avec souvent des réchauds
dit je vous aurais beaucoup mieux
classés moi à moi moi moi j'ai choisi
l'émission de coluche info ce qui
faisait une émission sur canal qui
auront ils revisitent et l'information à
la façon qu l'ust est due à une star à
l'époque voilà il est arrivé sur canal
il n'est pas resté longtemps puisqu'il
s'est fait viré au bout de 6 8 mois ci
mais si mes souvenirs sont bons
moi j'étais petit gérard 10 ans et j'ai
avec qui je kiffais de ouf c'est le
rendez-vous en fait alors il parler de
l'actualité et il est des vannes voilà
regarder on en a sorti deux regarde et
je vais vous conter l'histoire de
boomerang mais je me rappelle plus enfin
c'est pas grave ça va me revenir
et bien maintenant une devinette est ce
que vous savez la différence qui entre a
et o environ 5 cm
merci
ah oui oui fabien le pire dans cette
c'est il faut remercier philippe gildas
d'avoir emmené justement coluche qui
était déjà sur europe 1 le 7 octobre 85
pour les fameux fonds de côté ça ils
adorent des cas une date il en numéro 7
elle en sait vous battiez de leurs mots
numéro 7 et qui avez vous choisi votre
ville a choisi quoi a voulu comme talon
qui a émergé de canal + sur canal
oui alors ouais tu hais les dimanches et
ce qui est amusant c'est que au début
quand et les chroniqueurs avant d'animer
l'émission parce que michel denisot va
se casser le bras au début alain de
greef qui est directeur des programmes
le vois pas ce que c'était enregistrait
la chronique et 10 les nus liban où il
est aucun charisme il n'y arrivera
jamais jamais jamais et en fait beckham
arrivé là-bas serait alors il pourrait
bien régler en fait il y en a il s'était
blessé parce qu'en fait il était
chroniqueur il était producteur de
l'émission et c'était denisot qui dès
qu'ils produisaient et un jour de nizon
ce kart bras voilà et il lui dit est-ce
que du coup tu veux l'animé et du coup
ils en panique totale il appelle son
pote à l'époque était de chavannes qui
était complètement à l'arrêt il est plus
d'émissions dechavanne vient dans
l'émission et il est tellement timide
qui pose des question maladroite et du
coup ça donne ce style un peu fogiel
alors qu'en fait c'était pas un style
il était juste c'était un gamin de 27
ans qui était maladroit il a animé
plusieurs émissions sur canal + dimanche
plussoie corte des plus sur la rd il y a
deux ans thierry ardisson a décidé de ne
plus montrer à la télé aujourd'hui le
fait une exception en étant le premier
invité de tv plus bonjour thierry non je
vais recevoir la première question est
simple pourquoi elle ne plus avoir
décidé de se montrer ce que vous avez un
problème avec votre image ce qu'il faut
savoir - d'abord c'est que quand j'avais
je pourrais 16 17 ans 18 ans mon
ambition ce n'était pas de devenir
animateur de télé quoi moi j'aurais
préféré être je perds ma fellini que guy
lux donc ça n'a jamais été ma vocation
touristique ce que fait lille
malheureusement en une année aussi
attendait bien l'époque ce caprice sont
brouillées il s'entendait bien l'époque
et après la fameuse guerre parce qu'en
fait fogiel était le vendredi en direct
le samedi
y'avait ardisson mais qui enregistrait
le jeudi soir et du coup se piquer leurs
invités et puis au début c'était
vraiment potes mais c'est toujours pas l
animateur a redit son pardon mais j'ai
pas que j'aime pas beaucoup milité très
pote avec avec fogiel tom faucher ils
étaient petits picots fogiel a grandi
pas forcément l'amitié partie et vous
avez vu comment la télé ça change
denisot et se casse le bras et laisse la
place à fogiel rock et ska le bras il a
dit pendant six semaines je vais venir
avec le bras cassé et sixième positions
c'est vous agace
j'avais choisi quoi ah oui et le service
après vente des émissions mais lui cette
saison
d'omar et fred c'est vrai vous avez une
petite compil justement ces sixièmes
regarder des trucs cool de canal + ebr
bonjour du doubs j'ai vu une annonce à
la crise je peux pas la rue te louper
justement ma fille serait pour sauver la
zone euro
ah bon oui il y avait du monde à manger
vais je peux dire aux mains j'écoutais
beaucoup de liquidités ah oui j'aime
beaucoup les beaucoup de crédit facile
bout bonjour tu l'aimés tu en connais
c'est ça qu'est ce que tu viens de me
donner sapin j'avais dit qu'est ce qu'il
nomme c'est parce que je tiens éduqué
mais je suis pas une dame bord dont les
bévues ses services à commande bonjour
ça va pas conne à tous qu'il ya un
monsieur
enfin c'est notre gros cons qu'ils
respectent pas la journée internationale
de la tolérance presse de fist s'est
classé 6e ça c'est un très gros et faut
savoir que omar et fred c'est qu'ils
sont beaucoup cherché au départ 1 sur
canal ils ont fait plein de trucs ils
ont fait le visiophone tout ça et après
ils ont trouvé ça et c'est vrai que
c'était ça a été un énorme carton
bravo à eux en tout cas brandon top 5 et
de ce qui a marqué les années canal et
ce qui a été classé numéro 5
c'est vous selon michel merde c'est
votre choix c'est quoi a titre perso
j'aurais pu le night show parce que
franchement c'est pas moi c'est vrai
mais j'ai décidé de plus éclectiques
jambes j'ai pris du temps mais voilà
c'était c'était illégal c'est mais c'est
toujours des moments de télé puis ça a
révélé plein d actrice louise bourgoin
charlotte le bon qui d'autre chose ils
ont créé quelque chose eh ouais alors
c'est vrai que j'adore s'était elle
n'est pour donner la météo après ça
devenait vite inscrit à ce cadre là
c'était ça et il y en a eu beaucoup
beaucoup qui sont passés y en a certains
majorité oubliée et d'autres ont
particulièrement marqué l'émission on
vous a fait une confidence à voir donc
vous vouliez axelle laffont louise
bourgoin et doriath il y est notamment
regarder axel rioux accès les loups axa
est ce que quelqu'un peut les récupérer
recherché axel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'occupe de la météo autrement dit je
suis humoriste et ce soir je suis assez
embêter puisque arrivé après une
discussion aussi grave ait fait rire
c'est pas évident donc je vais
simplement présenter la météo mais je
vous demanderais d'avoir la gentillesse
de rire au moins pendant les
températures sinon je vais me faire
virer un point alors évitez le public
sait que vous êtes nombreux à me
regarder
et justement un préliminaire de mise en
bouche je tenais à vous dire que pas mal
l'été vous m'avez trop mannequin mais
grave coiffera un chemin franchement
j'ai été très peiné est même double
pénis est vous avez axelle laffont l'ars
et c'est une histoire avec ce que j'ai
accès là vous jeter sur stagiaires n'ont
été très sympa détestons s'agira comédie
très gentil et louise bourgoin
louise bourgoin qui s'appelle ariane
envoyé non s'appelle ariane en vrai
parce que je connaissais depuis
longtemps parce qu'elle était sur filles
tv et pardon vous connaissez toutes les
miss météo voudrait pas dire que ce
qu'on était tous les amis avec la prière
et un coup c'est à gannat d'un jeu samir
amin ont été vite et d'amis avec ariel
sap la rue n en fait elle s'appelait le
oui elle était sur filles tv et je vais
demander j'ai fait une émission sur
direct 8 ya très longtemps et on avait
animé ensemble je vais demander je
l'avais repérée sur filles tv on avait
fait un truc ensemble et c'est vrai
après là elle m'avait appelé shu jure
que c'est vrai ma vie dit on m'a demandé
cyril de faire le casting pour être miss
météo qu'est ce t'en pense pas moi
j'étais jeune j'étais au chômage donc je
dis franchement et elle m'a dit elle
m'appelait malimba voilà j'ai été pris
sous sa on avait fait une très belle
fête voilà merci donc je l'embrassais
louise et ariane aussi en quatrième
position
c'est sait qui c'est c'est fabien le
cinéma de jamel ça c'est la deuxième
vague et canal+ l'esprit canal deuxième
vague 1998 et là on voit toute la
l'insolence du personnage et la
tendresse quand il nous présente les
films ça c'était formidable débute à vue
lundi par le lancement alors venez sur
france 3 alors y'a du y avait il y avait
10km bien sûr dans le cinéma de diabète
il y avait aussi il était dans h et
kerry car bien sûr il avait aussi fait
un passage remarqué à cannes sur le
plateau de nulle part ailleurs
ah oui laetitia casta formica mail et
ctv cbc ça t'est jamais dbsa dijon mais
qu'est ce qui vous dit l'artiste qui dit
qu'ils voulaient attendre le mois de mai
mais c'est pas possible en attendant le
moins de montner
non mais là quand la tête mais la cat la
cadhp la caf garde yvo de boer gold tu
veux boire un pack le guen patrick est
fait un gros plan par un oui des gens on
est activée ouais ouais ça va ça va
on va rentrer maintenant dans le top 3
ce qu'a choisi la rédaction vol qf32 ce
qui a marqué les années canal et
benjamin castaldi vous êtes troisième à
me passer de caunes garcia et n'oubliez
je me précipite et je ne voulais pas en
rater un c'est vraiment un duo
exceptionnel pas bon et ça c'était
l'esprit canal alors il est des
personnages
j'ai envie de vous remettre un extrait
de richard jouir et cindy trop fort et
je voudrais dire voilà tu sais c'est
vrai qu'ils sont toujours très très bien
tous les deux c'est sa vie des
chauffeurs de salle et le gars est en
fait il était chauffeur de salle à la
base et surtout en de caunes qui a vu
qu'il était et dark a eu ni ma viande
rouge rien
[Applaudissements]
france marcal je suis richard jouir et
voici sandrine trop forte
nous alimentons bavure de mode le
fan-club de richard geere et de cindy
crawford
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oh
il
j'ai vu ton film à cannes ahmad kellogg
l'écossé 100 kg qui met tout le monde
sur le carreau et que c'est car au
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hockey
et les autres on va rentrer dans le top
2 et eric eric naulleau c'est vous qui
êtes numéro 2 ce soir vous avez choisi
les guignols les guignols
dans ce cas le plus marqué canal+ pour
une émission satirique qui a
curieusement transformer certaines
personnalités en personnage culte alors
ppd le le présentateur même si jacques
chirac
on a bien sûr beaucoup aux guignols
mêmes sylvester stallone qu'on a
découvert dans un rôle différent
alors qu'amd a ressorti deux extraits
des guignols voulait dire quelque chose
29 autres 88 4 ans après la création de
canal + d'accord digues les premières
minutes c'était gildas des pda et anne
sinclair traiter les trois premiers
c'est bien parfois non non j'ai rien
dans mes bras vous j'adore avec sa du ça
dure et que maintenant ça dure et ça
c'est à ça s'est arrêté en demi alors on
vous l'avait d'ailleurs diffusé une
compilation des meilleurs moments de
chaque chirac dont les guignols le jour
de sa disparition
c'est un des personnages cultes des
guignols mais on a eu beaucoup d'autres
on a envie de vous mettre une petite
blague de michel denisot et une
intervention du fameux away sylvestre
sylvester stallone regarde la dette
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qui lé long dur et que
les fans n'ont pas celle à michel hallé
connu assez le service militaire
non c'est la [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
ayrault le serveur ans il est alors oui
bah aussi sergent là après ce matin vous
avez réussi l'exploit de tuer l'un des
chefs d'al qaïda au yémen où se tenant
du nous était donc au yémen cacher avant
un enjeu de chez moi au texas commença à
bages pilote des drones se sentent plus
chez moi
ah bon sans manquer de respect à nos
âmes et des terroristes
quand j'ai tué votre chef j'étais aux
chiottes faisait pop au pardon ah bah
ouais moi je pilote le drone depuis mon
ipod
[Applaudissements]
enfin salle qui est numéro 1 c'est celle
qu'elle choisit c'est ce qu'a choisi
isabelle morini bosc est numéro 1
isabelle vous avez choisi quoi pour
musique a le plus marqué les nuls voilà
les nuls pour cette 1992 bruno carette
alain chabat dominique farrugia et
chantal lauby avec le faux journal il
osé tout et c'est pour ça qu'on les
mêmes vous souvenez ah oui oh vous savez
un tampax vers l oreille à bompas que
j'ai mis mon stylo à la hausse y aller
on a fait un tour directement sur france
dans cet extrait on retrouve se trouve
encore un guest chantal lauby nous
explique comment elle s'est mise au
sport regarde un peu plaisir en forme
comme ça pénélope
oui je me suis fait deux heures et demie
de gym super 2h30 de gypsy punk gym gym
simon gillett jour j
elle est donc deux heures et demie vous
savez j'ai pas de mérite c'est lui qui
fait tout le travail
on a aussi une parodie de clips vous
rappelez de david et jonathan tient pas
d'accord c'est est ce que tu viens pour
les vacances des fêtes de mercy regarde
[Musique]
moi j'en ai
à malley
[Musique]
en mal
deux cent dix mois
qu'est ce que tu vaux
à caen
les casots et
emma
je ne
vous
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est jean marie bigard bien sûr avec la
pub
tony blonde voilà ça c'est sûr que c'est
la gamme de castanet un vieux qu'est ce
qui t'arrive n'en sais rien mais quand
je me lave jeunes un peu mal à fait
gaffe c'est vachement important
tiens regarde tu vois ça c'est ma [ __ ]
les impurs thèse dépose la entre le
poêler les couilles tu fais ce que tu
veux mais moi je me brosse régulièrement
l'habite avec tony glande il tenait
gandil ouais et je peux te dire qu'avec
ça m'habite c'est du béton et celui qui
j je suis grâce à lui la aujourd'hui
puisque c'est lui qui m'a fait
travailler sur comédie voilà j'ai fait
un gros bisou à dominique on les a placé
numéro 1 voilà les street et culture
qu'elle a pu sceller 35 ans 2 canal+